you know we got AC here which is great
but next door fortunately we have no HP
next door oh my god did you film the
fridge this is Mike Mike exactly oh this
is weird-looking how old she she's like
eight months old
like the cheese mommy isn't cheese sauce
get better longer agent well you think
it smells like really it tastes like
super hot today is the Sam and I are in
the studio air-conditioned in there
totally night Jake Carmichael Bren
they're all off at VidCon today we'll be
going tomorrow probably wondering why I
have a gas mask in my hands
stay tuned this one there's no like a
pile of boxes next to Christians desk
like the past two weeks and with no one
here we figure we can open them and not
get yelled at
right because we're in charge right Sam
we are now ha ha no one here to stop us
what's up watch what we have so many
[ __ ] spinners this is that's too bad
didn't we like we just shot that busy
center video ha a challenging schedule
the rule that's been out there simple
whoever is still spinning the longest
wins alright I'm here to keep opening
boxes because it's gonna take a while
three you one thing now I got shitty
spin this time anyway cousin their
chemical gel flying materials Oh the
less Neil Islan Island oh my god whoa
whoa or well the nerf zombies comes
either grapes and brick from the nerf
stylus be with us via hardpoint
we got suction tip I can do actually
really cool man how's it going good
going go yeah go spin it I think I got
this
hold on
oh my god that's like he just doped up
your sinner I just open up that's so
much more satisfying than a normal Dart
you got are you going for yeah either
the rifled ones the AXI strikes get the
glass oh I'm blonde my spinner my studio
still appear one I mean I think if I
like moving like this oh oh yeah whoa
all right see it's spinning and I can
stop it take your ad just say you walk a
lot same ones maybe we're the ones
sitting in the center zeg it's pretty
neat so it might make you be one and
then he left it in the fridge here and
never came to get it so we've got open
it in here okay punching okay with you
that you're maturing box
are you maturing mica dammit earn a lot
Nile I really don't want to tell that
right like it actually smells really
strong cheese I know but like good like
a jet stream of pungent air into my
throat you know dude you don't want to
eat that atomic the worst melted but
it's very satchel incredibly saturated
oh it's like the whiskey the Scotch have
smelled this is interesting
ropes on the service I cannot really
grow just like well the rind of achieves
actually mold like REE that lights up
I'm a sin to mold this balls get really
dry is like crumble dude named yo-yo
then the multi man is an experiment fine
ready okay we have a legit unopened box
pi you literally two more here so I got
married to spats with him that's pretty
cool
confit on my family and friends on you
in LA really enjoyed it is really
wholesome he has everything I'm getting
married worth checking out worthy for
the stains a box in a part in a bag and
a to dr. Knight oh is this a new for you
scream no it is like a power supply
powered green oh oh is this a key no oh
wait a second this is power
what is this oh my it's a lightning law
notices the power supply next big I feel
like that right now
so this is a falcon eyes roh-roh light
it's called the rolex LED light and it's
ready for some Rolex to bring it in a
little bit more a little more for
testing up the light happiness I'm going
to go down give me like an edge light
let's demo that let's do an edge light
here that's good pretty good
it's just a little left or camera left
no no my life haven't [ __ ]
Brown
breathe does it will be like Greek all
smelly what I pay you today about a bite
of that I could make it was just a
grilled cheese with it Oh a good way to
make me never want to eat cheese we get
a nice that why didn't it grow up to be
a full team because we never had a
father but I'm good at this guy's
microwave oh no it's in here oh my god
oh it's poppin' well do you get a macro
shot of this I don't I knew this is on
down Oh God
oh my god this is not that bad but my
grave in that cheese oh my god that's me
baked in there
wait they're way better these are
blasted with positive flavors you got an
evil spirits never do that then I'm
killed 100 people fling Bell around
yeah so that you want up yesterday
clearly like the day before this video
of mine it's late a zombie game which is
where you have everybody get on your
server but they all agree to take off
their clothes and use melee only weapons
and try to kill you so it's kind of like
the nerf zombie game in real life
everyone says it's impossible to win
this game mode the best part is probably
when we threw a Molotov and two
stairwell at the same time they all push
through and so just a bunch of burning
zombies to rinse the door and we're just
all unloading our guns as fast as we can
and we speeding up no no no